>> Laura: AGITATORS, NOT
EDUCATORS, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
WHAT IS TODAY FALLS CHURCH,
VIRGINIA, WAS AN EARLY COLONIAL
SETTLEMENT DATING BACK TO THE
LATE 1600s.
IT WAS FOUNDED IN 1734 AND
DERIVED ITS NAME FROM THE FALLS
CHURCH, AN EPISCOPAL
CONGREGATION.
IT DIDN’T BECOME ITS OWN
INDEPENDENT CITY UNTIL 1948 WHEN
PARENTS SUCCESSFULLY OBTAINED
SEPARATION FROM FAIRFAX COUNTY
IN AN EFFORT TO ESTABLISH A
HIGHLY ACCLAIMED SCHOOL SYSTEM.
72 YEARS LATER, FALLS CHURCH HAS
ABANDONED ITS ORIGINAL MISSION.
JUST AS HUNDREDS OF SCHOOL
SYSTEMS ACROSS AMERICA ARE USING
THE COVID EXCUSE, THE FALLS
CHURCH SCHOOL BOARD SINCE LAST
MARCH HAS CLOSED ITS SCHOOLS FOR
IN PERSON LEARNING AND IT’S
TURNED ITS STUDENT BODY INTO
ZOOM BOTS.
IT LOCKED ONTO SCREENS FOR HOURS
A DAY OF VIRTUAL LEARNING WHERE
KIDS ARE LEARNING VIRTUALLY
NOTHING.
DESPITE NO EVIDENCE OF SCHOOLS
AS MAJOR SPREADERS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS, DESPITE THE FACT
THAT DR. FAUCI IN THE CDC SAID
SCHOOL SHOULD BE OPEN, THE LEFT
HAS REFUSED TO BRING STUDENTS
BACK FULL-TIME.
JUST LIKE THE NEARBY LIBERAL
ENCLAVES OF FAIRFAX COUNTY AND
MONTGOMERY COUNTY, MARYLAND, BUT
DON’T THINK THAT DURING THE
SHUTDOWN, FALLS CHURCH SCHOOL
BOARD HASN’T BEEN KEEPING ITSELF
VERY BUSY.
ON TUESDAY NIGHT, UNANIMOUSLY
VOTED TO RENAME TURTLE SCHOOLS.
THOMAS JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY AND
GEORGE MASON HIGH, THESE
FOUNDING FATHERS APPARENTLY
OFFENDED RADICAL ACTIVISTS AND
THE SCHOOL BOARD CHAIR, TOTAL
PUSHOVER GREG ANDERSON JUST
ROLLED OVER.
>> AFTER DEEP AND CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF EVERYTHING THAT
I HAVE HEARD AND READ, I
CONCLUDE THAT RENAMING BOTH
SCHOOLS IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF OUR STUDENTS AND A NECESSARY
PART OF OUR EQUITY WORK.
>> Laura: EQUITY WORK?
AND YET THEY IGNORE THE FACT
THAT FOREIGN IMMIGRANT KIDS ARE
LOSING MORE GROUND EVERY DAY
THEY KEEP THESE SCHOOLS
SHUTTERED -- THESE PEOPLE DON’T
BELIEVE IN EQUITY, THEY BELIEVE
IN POWER.
THEY ARE NOT EDUCATORS, THEY ARE
AGITATORS.
>> IF OUR MANDATORY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS MAKE SOME OF OUR OWN
STUDENTS FEEL LESS WORTHY
BECAUSE OF THE NAME OVER THE
DOOR, THAT IS A BIG PROBLEM.
NO CHILD SHOULD EVER HAVE TO BE
IN A BUILDING WHERE THEY FEEL
MARGINALIZED.
I BELIEVE WE NEED TO FIND NAMES
THAT ARE WELCOMING TO ALL.
>> Laura: WELCOMING TO ALL.
LIKE COUNTLESS OTHER SCHOOLS
NATIONWIDE, FALLS CHURCH SHELLED
OUT THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL CONSULTANTS
TO NAVIGATE THE NAMING
CONTROVERSY.
FUNNY ENOUGH IN THAT SURVEY,
ONLY 26% WANTED GEORGE MASON
NAME TO CHANGE AND ONLY 23%
WANTED, THOMAS JEFFERSON’S NAME
TO CHANGE -- THE PETTY TYRANTS
ON THE BOARD SIMPLY IGNORED THIS
AND SIDED WITH THE PERJURER’S OF
HISTORY.
PARENT JENNIFER SANTIAGO SAYING
"WHILE THERE ARE MANY TIMES
MAJORITY RULES WORKS IN THE
ISSUES OF EQUITY, IT IS THE
OPPOSITE THAT IS NEEDED -- IT’S
THE MAJORITY RULE WORK FOR
TRADITIONALLY MARGINALIZED
GROUPS, WE WOULD NOT HAVE
SYSTEMIC RACISM.
"LOOK, IF THESE FOLKS REALLY
CARED ABOUT TRADITIONALLY
MARGINALIZED PEOPLE, STUDENTS,
KIDS, THEY WOULD BE SPENDING
THEIR TIME WORKING ON OPENING
THESE SCHOOLS.
AFTER THE LAST VOTE LAST NIGHT,
A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER BRAZENLY
ADMITTED THEIR REAL AGENDA.
>> THE CRITICAL MOMENT FOR ME
WAS THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, I
WAS PROUD IN THE FALLS CHURCH
CITY, THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDACY
USED EQUITY AND INCLUSION ONE
WITH 80% OF THE VOTE.
HOWEVER, OUTSIDE OF FALLS CHURCH
APPROACHING HALF THE COUNTRY
VOTED FOR THE OTHER CANDIDATE.
THAT CANDIDATE PUT CHILDREN IN
CAGES, HE SAID THERE WERE GOOD
PEOPLE AMONG THE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS MARCHING IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
HE STOPED DIVISION AT EVERY
TURN.
I AM APPALLED BOTH BY HIS
BEHAVIOR AND WHAT THE VOTE MEANS
FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: YOU DON’T THINK
THESE SCHOOLBOARD ELECTIONS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT?
THIS IS WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO
START RUNNING FOR THESE SEATS
AND KNOCKING OUT THESE
GOOFBALLS.
THIS RADICAL RABID LEFTIST.
I BET AFTER SEEING THIS MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS ARE APPALLED
BECAUSE THEY DON’T REALLY KNOW,
THEY AREN’T THINKING ABOUT HOW
POLITICIZED EDUCATION HAS BECOME
BECOME.
IT’S CLEAR THAT CHILDREN AREN’T
CONCERNED FOR THESE NEO-MARXISTS
THAT ARE RUNNING EDUCATION, IT’S
ALL ABOUT REMAKING AMERICA.
>> WE NEED TO FIGHT INEQUALITY
AND RACISM WITH ACTION.
WE NEED AS WE ARE TO REFORM
CURRICULUM AND WORK TO EDUCATE
STUDENTS TO UNDERSTAND THE
MEANING OF HISTORY, DIVERSITY,
EQUITY, AND INCLUSION POLICY FOR
OUR SCHOOLS THAT UNITES US AND
SPECIFIES FURTHER ACTION.
WE SHOULD MAKE A STATEMENT THAT
WE BELIEVE ALL PEOPLE ARE
CREATED EQUAL.
THOMAS JEFFERSON WROTE ALMOST
THOSE VERY WORDS AND WE CAN
BETTER LIVE UP TO THE GOAL HE
SET I KNOW LONGER HAVING A
SCHOOL NAMED FOR HIM.
>> Laura: THAT MAN COULD BE
WITHIN 100 YARDS OF ANY SCHOOL
SHOULD TERRIFY ALL OF US.
THIS AGGRESSIVE CAMPAIGN OF
WOKENESS AND REWRITING HISTORY
IS HAPPENING ALL ACROSS AMERICA,
AND FARGO, NORTH DAKOTA, WHERE
STUDENTS ARE IN A HYBRID
LEARNING MODEL, THE SCHOOL BOARD
IS SPENDING ITS TIME VIRTUAL
SIGNALING ABOUT ITS HORRIBLE
PAST.
>> IF DAKOTA IS A CHOSEN NAME, I
THINK WE WOULD WANT TO DO WORK
TO MAKE SURE WE AREN’T DEFENDING
A COMMUNITY BY ASSIGNING A
MASCOT THAT’S ASSOCIATED WITH A
NAME AS WELL.
>> WHAT ARE WE HOPING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN AS A RESULT OF A NEW
NAME?
IS IT TO HONOR SOMEONE?
IS IT TO BUILD A STORY?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION
THAT THE BOARD SELECTED DAKOTA
HIGH SCHOOL AS THE NEW NAME FOR
WOODROW WILSON HIGH SCHOOL.
>> Laura: THAT MOTION OF
COURSE PASSED YESTERDAY.
THE DAY BEFORE THAT, SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN ST. PAUL, MINNESOTA,
DECIDED HAVING A SCHOOL NAMED
AFTER THE STATE’S FIRST GOVERNOR
WAS ALSO FAR TO TRIGGERING.
>> I THINK THIS RIPPLE EFFECT OF
CREATING A CULTURE OF DIVISION
WHERE SOME PEOPLE FEEL LESS THAN
OR SOME PEOPLE FEEL SINGLED OUT
OR SOME PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
ARE NOT REAL PEOPLE, PROLONGING
THIS ISSUE, KEEPING THIS NAME
LINGERING AROUND, KNOWING WHAT
WE KNOW IS A PUBLIC ENDORSEMENT.
>> Laura: A PUBLIC ENDORSEMENT
ENDORSEMENT.
YOU CAN BET THE TEACHERS UNIONS
THINK ALL OF THIS NONSENSE IS
FANTASTIC.
EVERYONE IS A VICTIM IN THIS
GAME.
THESE LIBERAL SCHOOL BOARDS
DON’T BLINK WITHOUT CONSULTING
THE NEA FIRST AND THAT BRINGS US
TO JOE BIDEN.
>> YOU DON’T JUST HAVE A PARTNER
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU WILL
HAVE AN NEA MEMBER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND IF I’M NOT
LISTENING I WILL BE SLEEPING
ALONE IN THE LINCOLN BEDROOM.
>> IT TAKES A LOT OF MONEY TO
GET THEM BACK, THE ESTIMATES ARE
150 TO $200 BILLION TO SAFELY
REOPEN THE SCHOOLS.
>> Laura: REPUBLICANS
SHOULDN’T GIVE THEM A PENNY, WE
KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO USE THAT
CASH TO HIRE MORE CONSULTANTS
AND MORE PROPAGANDISTS WHO TEACH
OUR KIDS TO HATE AMERICA, ITS
FOUNDERS, AND ITS FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS.
KIDS ARE GOING TO LEARN HOW
ROTTEN OUR COUNTRY IS, HOW
RACIST OUR FOUNDERS WERE AND HOW
IGNORANT MOST AMERICANS ARE.
THESE EDUCATION BUREAUCRATS
SHOULD FOCUS ON THE REAL
PROBLEMS, SCHOOL CLOSURES ARE
HARMING OUR CHILDREN -- THIS
FROM THE AP, AMERICAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FROM DISTRICTS FROM
COAST TO COAST HAVE REPORTED THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS FAILING
CLASSES HAS RISEN BY AS MANY TWO
OR THREE TIMES, STUDENTS
LEARNING FROM HOMES GIVE
ASSIGNMENTS OR SCHOOL
ALTOGETHER.
HERE’S A POP QUIZ, WHAT IS MORE
DAMAGING TO A CHILD?
THE NAME ON THE SCHOOL BUILDING?